he's one of nascar's biggest names a cup
champion
and this season he already has won one
or he has
one win excuse me he has one win 11 top
five finishes
and 17 top tens mercedes talked to the
driver of the number 19 bass pro shops
car
martin truex jr as we prepare for nascar
in vegas
it's so great to talk to you 2020 has
been quite a year
uh just for you personally with the
racing doing great and then also with
this whole pandemic how is how has 2020
racing been for you
well it's been a lot different than what
we're used to that's for sure obviously
um
you know going all the way back to i
guess it was may when we
uh well we had to stop racing for two
months and then
you know coming back from that um
there's so much is
has been different this season than what
we're accustomed to um
whether it's you know we're talking no
practice no qualifying on the race
weekends
um one day shows sometimes double
headers sometimes you know
midweek races i mean it's been a lot
different
and um you know for me it's it's taking
a little getting used to i think the
biggest thing that uh
that's made it different is the lack of
the fans at the racetrack because
you know the fans are such a big part of
nascar and such a big part of
our sport and our weekly our weekend
shows and so it's been
it's been you know a bit odd from that
standpoint as well it's nice that you
guys are coming back to las vegas we
look forward to seeing the race out here
for you
what's what's your best thing about
racing in vegas and what's the worst
thing about racing in vegas
uh the best thing is the track is great
and
you know usually the fans are great out
there i don't know how many we're going
to have this time around i haven't
actually heard but
um the track's awesome it's a lot of fun
to race on the chance of it being you
know 110 degrees or something like that
that's really that's really about the
only bad part about going to vegas
yeah that could the weather can be rough
is it weird though that i always go
to the big bass pro shop on over by the
silverton and hope that i catch a
glimpse of you when the race is in town
it's not weird and and sometimes i go
there and sign autographs so you just
you haven't came at the right time i
guess
before i let you go martin i wanted to
know if you've ever heard of this game
before it's called
that was awkward have you ever heard of
this
i have not share three things you're
happy about right
now but yell them as loud as you can
yell them again yeah
we're going to richmond this week
i
[Laughter]